we all know in our hearts that godzilla
is the king of monsters but although the
towering creature has been a fixture on
our screens for decades
there's still plenty of stuff most
people don't know about the history of
the franchise
here's the untold truth of godzilla
given that he's largely known for
starring in a series of cheapy creature
features
it's easy to forget godzilla was
originally intended as a heavy-handed
and fairly blunt metaphor for the
dangers of nuclear weapons
as the scars of world war ii have faded
this aspect of godzilla's character has
been toned down somewhat
in favor of showing the big g
backhanding creatures
from a city block away with his tail
this said godzilla's roots are still
subtly represented in his character
design
specifically his skin the original
godzilla suit which has served as the
basis of every iteration of the
character since
was directly inspired by the horrific
burns and scars of the unfortunate souls
who survived the nuclear blasts at
hiroshima
and nagasaki this was done to serve as a
constant reminder that godzilla was born
as a direct result of a nuclear weapons
test
it also possibly explains why he screams
so much
since it suggests he's in near constant
pain
watching some of the fight scenes in his
earlier movies you'd be forgiven for
thinking that godzilla's entire fighting
style
revolves around throwing clumsy claw
swipes and haphazard tail swings at his
enemies
you know except for that one time he
dominates megalom with a dropkick
delivered at mach 3
with the help of jet jaguar as it turns
out though
godzilla actually fought using more
grace than most would give him credit
for
and in fact technically has a black belt
in judo
the actor who first played godzilla haru
nakajima became so accustomed to the
weight and limitations of the godzilla
suit
that he was largely given free reign to
script and choreograph
all of his own fight scenes nakajima who
had a black belt in judo
spent many years perfecting godzilla's
fighting style
basing it mainly on judo and adapting
for godzilla's ambling bulk and large
lizardy girth
this is why if you watch early films in
which nakajima played godzilla
you'll notice he seems to favor
chokeholds and throws
supplemented by blasts of atomic fire
breath something was sure would be a
part of actual judo if it was possible
in his original movie incarnation
godzilla stood about 164 feet tall
and has gotten suddenly taller with each
reboot of the franchise
more than doubling in height to about
390 feet tall
in the latest japanese film you're
probably thinking that increasing
godzilla's height has a lot to do with
the ever-increasing size of modern
buildings and you'd be right but there's
slightly more to it than that
in the original 1954 movie a conscious
decision was made that godzilla had to
be just slightly taller than every
building he appeared next to
the idea behind this being that godzilla
would be visible on the city's skyline
no matter where you were
making him an ever-present threat to
make this possible
buildings that were taller than godzilla
at the time were deliberately scaled
down further than others when
constructing miniatures
as the skyline of japan got bigger so
did godzilla although this idea dropped
by the wayside for more recent movies as
making godzilla the size of modern
skyscrapers
would make him too big a problem we
wouldn't think anyone would care about
until we heard that prior to the release
of the 2014 movie hundreds of people
called the new design
fat next to the wilhelm scream and that
stuck noise of a dolphin you always seem
to hear in terrible movies
no noise in cinematic history it's as
recognizable as godzilla's raw
initially created by rubbing a leather
glove along the strings of a bass guitar
the original recording of the raw is
safely kept in touhou's offices
occasionally being used to service the
basis of an updated version
using the method used to create the
original roar as a starting point
the sound designers for the 2014 movie
worked in secret to create the new
updated godzilla raw
if you look in the art book released
alongside the movie godzilla the art of
destruction
they tell you exactly how they did it
they used the sound of dry ice on a
metal vent
some crunching rocks and the noise made
by a wooden crate being dragged across a
polished floor
when the sound engineers had the final
version of the raw they got in contact
with the rolling stones and asked to
borrow the speakers they used on tour
then played the raw through them as
loudly as possible the resulting noise
was so loud
it shook windows for several blocks and
caused a terrified executive at
universal studios three miles away
to call and ask what was going on
since we've talked about the 2014
godzilla movie we might as well talk
about the 1998 one too
and share the fact that touhou hated it
so much they changed the canon of the
franchise to erase it from existence
as bad as the reaction to the 1998 film
was in the west
in japan it was so so much worse one of
the actors who actually played godzilla
kenpachiro satsuma went so far as to
walk out of an early screening
angrily telling everyone present it's
not godzilla it doesn't have his spirit
along with its unappealing design many
japanese critics pointed out that it
didn't make
sense that a creature birthed by a
nuclear explosion seemed afraid of
missiles shot from helicopters when
rights of the franchise reverted back to
touhou after tristar wisely
chose not to try making a sequel to the
1998 movie
the company started a systematic
campaign to wipe it out of official
godzilla history
the company started by dubbing the
creature zilla as a nod to tristar
taking quotes
god out of godzilla then put it into the
film godzilla final wars
where it was unceremoniously clubbed to
death by the real godzilla
you'd assume based on the fact he's
destroyed tokyo half a dozen times in
his movies
creates earthquakes with his every step
and is a giant atomic lizard
the city wouldn't really be a big fan of
godzilla however the city not only loves
their resident radioactive reptile
they've bestowed several unique honors
upon him granting him official japanese
citizenship
and even offering him a job as a tourism
ambassador for the shujinko district
though positioned mostly as a pr move
shujinko officials nonetheless went out
of their way to make godzilla's
citizenship and job offer legitimate
or as legitimate as they can be given
he's a big fictional lizard
along with releasing an official copy of
his citizenship papers to the public as
a souvenir
godzilla was awarded a nice sash in
honor of his contributions to japanese
culture
which a guy in costume accepted on his
behalf shujinko was so pleased to
godzilla accepting the position of
tourism ambassador that they built a
giant statue of him
although he weighs several thousand tons
is several dozen stories tall and
has tiny almost comically stubby arms
godzilla is surprisingly agile for his
size the exact extent of his ability
varies from movie to movie
with arguably the greatest and most
unexpected demonstration of his agility
occurring in the 1971 movie godzilla
vs hedorah using his atomic breath
godzilla can propel himself through the
air at several hundred miles per hour
along with increasing godzilla's aerial
combat capabilities exponentially
and melting minds with its sheer
stupidity the feat raises some serious
questions about just how powerful
godzilla's atomic breath is
as it can produce enough force to propel
him through the air
the folks over the youtube channel death
battle actually worked this out
and figured out that his breath produced
about 328 trillion pounds of force
per square inch
with the exception of american remakes
and a few scenes in shin godzilla
godzilla has almost universally been
created using the tried and true guy and
big rubber suit method
over the years the suits worn by the
actors portraying the radioactive
reptile
have gotten increasingly sophisticated
which is probably a good thing
since early suits nearly killed the men
wearing them as recounted in the 2004
behind the scenes documentary bringing
godzilla down to size
it kind of sucked for the actors who
have had the honor of stepping into the
suit's big rubber boots
along with being uncomfortable
cumbersome and unflattering on the
thighs the suit was almost unthinkably
heavy with early versions weighing
roughly 220 pounds
this made even walking in the suit and
almost herculean feet and the actors
explained that they frequently became
dangerously dehydrated
for stunt scenes particularly ones
involving water the suit posed an
especially significant hazard
both nakajima and satsuma noted that
they were almost killed doing
water-based stunts
nakajima has reported that he had a
particular distaste for water stunts
because he knew the other actors peed in
the pool
godzilla is so powerful that we think of
him as invincible no matter the obstacle
we're always seeing the same towering
monster rampaging through the city and
besting his foes
one piece of less common knowledge is
that godzilla has actually died several
times
while he has come back from the grave on
occasion he's permanently died more than
once
what does this mean for the franchise is
continuity simply
puts it isn't one monster with the
different designs running through the
touhou series but multiple members of
the same species
all called godzilla while it's known
that godzilla species could have
multiple members
it's less commonly known that the touhou
films also feature different godzillas
rather than a single character first and
foremost in the original 1954 godzilla
king of the monsters was famously
defeated by the oxygen destroyer weapon
killing him and leaving nothing but
bones people of the world
godzilla is dead characters speculate
that there could be another godzilla out
there
but when godzilla reemerges in godzilla
raids again it's a brand new
entirely different member of his species
setting the template for subsequent
appearances
2016's shin godzilla is the first and
only film so far of its continuity
reimagining godzilla as a new form of
rapidly evolving organism
a kind of prehistoric marine animal
whose evolutionary journey is kicked off
by nuclear waste on the ocean floor the
film depicts godzilla as an aggressive
and increasingly powerful creature
who evolves rapidly into a succession of
different forms
culminating in its fourth a massive
hulking monstrosity
that devastates tokyo until in the
middle of an unfinished fifth evolution
he's exposed to a massive amount of
blood coagulant that freezes him solid
the ending of the film starts to show
the form that godzilla had been evolving
into
his body opening to expose a number of
smaller humanoid entities
according to the art of shin godzilla
book and other official publications
the fifth form was intended to have new
powers like indefinite self-division
while being able to regenerate from the
smallest particle
while it's difficult to say if there
will be a direct sequel to shin godzilla
to take this story further it has
intriguing possibilities for the
franchise as a whole
godzilla is the star of a multimedia
empire that covers everything from film
and television
to video games and comic books including
a brief stint as a marvel comic star
that saw the colossal creature fight a
host of superheroes between 1977 and
1979
marvel comics published 24 issues of
godzilla king of the monsters
notably this series saw the first time
he touched down on u.s soil and had
godzilla luck in combat with a number of
monsters and marvel characters
godzilla's comics history runs through
an array of companies
after the characters stint to marvel
publishing rights changed hands to
darkhorse comics
and eventually idw publishing in 2015
idw launched a five-issue series written
by multiple authors and
illustrators called godzilla in hell
which sees the massive beast fall into
the mouth of hell
in each issue he fights other worldly
original kaiju
or variants of his own cast of demonic
creatures
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one